To the outside world the Amish seem kind, loving, generous.
But the odds of an Amish woman getting raped
by a guy within their own community?
It's one out of every six...
on a good day.
First perpetrator was my biological father.
I was five.
The Amish carved out a different way of existing.
The church wields power and control.
Under the church, the wives only have as much voice
as their husbands allow.
They bussed in four busloads of Amish people.
Not a single one of them was there in court for me.
Amish communities view going to the police
as a greater sin than the rape itself.
It's a predator's paradise.
It takes a courageous person
to go against that community.
Sometimes we have to face our biggest fear.
He wants two years work release,
no incarceration.
He is a pedophile!
We are the crack in the dam.
But when that flood comes,
justice has to follow.